we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
what were you saying about nature nature
is vicious it's funny when people kind
of romanticize
nature and animals and everything to
being this like
imaginary yeah like oh it's wonderful
it's an ecosystem it's like nah dude
there's no feelings it's just [ __ ]
eat or be eaten yeah you'll see like a
little calf being born and it still has
all the [ __ ]
sack all over it and then a [ __ ]
predator comes and just eats it and
you're like i'm hungry full
yeah in my world ants don't sing songs
just put it like that they are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and i hate them true apparently so are
[ __ ] so
this story is about a [ __ ] fighting ring
so the
rooster type of [ __ ] so in the
philippines
cockfighting is a pretty big sport oh i
heard about this
you heard about it yes it's it's the
most ironic it's
when i first read the headline i was
like funny
but then you think about it it's like
not so funny but here here's the story
so in
the philippines cockfighting is a it's a
very popular gathering of sorts a social
situation
yeah and recently the philippines have
basically said
no more cockfighting because you guys
are gathering not for the sake of the
uh rooster lies no it's not for cops
yes so they're like dude you guys are
spreading kovid so stop the [ __ ]
fighting
uh [ __ ] the [ __ ] anyways who cares
about the [ __ ]
all right so anyways there was a uh
there were a few farmers that actually
got together for an illegal fight
and honestly the there was only ten
dollars worth of cash
in the pot so it's a very small
operation but the philippines police
caught wind of this
and they came in and to shut it down and
uh
they caught one of a 10 gambling
operation yes that that's all they found
was 10
in cash is it a lot over there though uh
550 pesos
maybe it's a lot for that village yeah i
don't know it could be a
to me it sounds like if we did a
friendly poker game
and then like it was like a hundred
bucks yeah or whatever right or 50 bucks
it's just a game
but then the con but they they're
treating it like it's a huge gambling
distinction right yeah and apparently
there were only three farmers well it
says three farmers who have been taking
part in the legal fight were arrested
and three others were being sought so
six people people so in america that
should be okay if [ __ ] fighting was uh
was legal yeah it was like a six person
poker tournament six person poker
tournament yeah game night at the
buddies house
yeah so they the authorities seized
seven roosters
uh and ten dollars worth of cash and
a pair of gaffs now a pair of gaffs is
the blade in which the roosters are tied
to
on their legs so yeah so for
cockfighting they add
little knives on their legs so when they
kick they can cut each other up oh my
god
yeah battlebots basically i did not know
that it's crazy
yeah and so uh and the headline that
caught my attention brothers
it says philippines police chief killed
by brewster while breaking up a [ __ ]
fight
the roosters [ __ ] the cop up yes
holy [ __ ] police chief the chief of
police
yes went to go bust this big gambling
den of six
farmers and he got a chicken
i mean a rooster [ __ ] killed him yes
i didn't know roosters could kill people
oh my god have you ever been attacked by
a rooster i've been chased by one yeah
this is a rooster with a knife i've been
chasing yes he was armed he was armed
is he in jail please tell me he's off
the [ __ ] street no he got killed
there's seven
seven roosters you got jumped by all
seven that'd be stupid that'd be kind of
funny
because i'm wondering how i'm trying to
think of a human not dying
yeah yeah yeah you get [ __ ] up by a
rooster but i don't know how you could
die from a rooster
so the story goes he uh his name was
lieutenant christian
balak uh and he bled to death
because his femoral artery got cut
so that knife sliced up very
specifically sliced on the artery and he
just bled out
because of the gaff yes and um and this
part's kind of like weird too
uh he was trying to confiscate the
roosters but the problem was the
rooster's blade may have been laced with
poison
oh so holy [ __ ] in the [ __ ] fighting
world i guess they also lace the
rooster's uh weapon with poison so they
can kill the other rooster
faster wow like van damme kickboxer man
when you [ __ ] dips it in glass and
all these different things
wait how bi how big can this blade be
for it to fit on a [ __ ] rooster
right let me show you the photo they're
not that big hold on let me show you the
photo
how big is this human so here's the
photo at the police show oh my
god that's crazy that's the knife that
that was taped around the the foot of
the roof
oh [ __ ] that's like a full-on swiss army
knife yeah
it's gonna cut so he got stabbed
straight up yeah wow so he got stabbed
just in the worst place possible you
play i don't know do you know where the
femoral artery is it's in here so like
if you get cut in here you probably got
three minutes to lift
where three minutes i never i don't know
is that your thigh your femur the artery
that runs along your face
it's a big ass [ __ ] baby yeah and you
probably got less than three minutes
before you bleed out
if i ever have a samurai sword and i'm
in a battle i'm not even gonna attack
the upper body no i'm just gonna attack
the legs yeah yeah you cut anyone the
big ones
like your brachial artery your femoral
artery it's
it squirts out like kill bill style
because the veins like the size of this
yeah and it's like like with every
heartbeat it goes
oh god less than three minutes you're
gone no taking [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he's like don't take a [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] i got myself kind of don't film the
artery
that's legal so there's nothing you can
do because then it also says police try
to slow the blood loss by tying the
clots
tightly around yeah that would help you
need a tummy tuck immediately but maybe
it's the poison that got to
maybe and then he also added but they
may have applied it in the wrong
side they tried the wrong way i don't
know i don't know what that means
you know what would be funny it's
bleeding up here they tie it down here
or if it's like bleeding from here don't
worry chief i give you cpr
they tied it on the other leg
right here it hurts okay i get the other
side professional
it's kind of a funny situation it's
ironic but yeah it's really [ __ ] up
and uh so yeah the whole provincial
police are mourning the loss
of uh do you get a purple heart from
getting [ __ ] up by a chicken
yeah i don't i don't want to go out like
that dead during what combat did you get
like the 21 gun salute
oh my god
is the rooster going to live or is he
going on death row really better [ __ ]
get lost
electric chad they eat them i don't
believe in the death penalty so i hope
he just gets life
okay which is like two more years or
something yeah yeah yeah
like six months or something yeah i
don't know they didn't say anything
about
the aftermath of uh the rooster can you
imagine being that kid like yeah
my dad he was the chief of police he got
killed
during a drug a gambling bust routine
gambling bus
a gambling bus and it was like oh [ __ ]
for real what happened
one of the roosters killed us
yeah i would have lied i would have just
said yeah like one of the
farmers uh shanked them i love that they
still finished the job though they still
got the rest of the roosters
that's true let them [ __ ] go you get
this guy's dying
that's true i know what are the roosters
why do they they're like just victims of
this whole thing they should just let
the roosters go well they were resisting
rust i mean
yes apparently yeah i mean yes and
they're they're armed and dangerous
they got wrinkled because they're a gang
you can't you you can't just take one of
them you got to take all of them
or else they're going to multiply wait
all the dudes multiply each other
do the farmers get charged with murder
oh yeah so the farmers are
uh imagine they just walk away they're
just like no you're good these
[ __ ] though
all the chickens yeah all the roosters
you know what actually doesn't say
war on roosters yeah i don't know what
what's gonna happen to the farmers but
you would think right
uh i guess based on american law
accessory
yeah okay it just sounds like this
article was so
just the sole purpose was to make fun of
the [ __ ] it is
it is common it is pretty funny follow
up on like those
sounds like a cartoon to us yeah because
i can't see anything so it's beautiful
yeah my friend had a um rooster that was
really [ __ ] aggressive
and then i hated going to his backyard i
was like
seven or eight and he goes no you just
gotta kick him and i'm like
they don't stop what he's like yeah it's
like as long as you kick
him he's like you'll be okay he could
kick him it's okay and he goes out and
then the rooster tries to come
and he just [ __ ] kicks him real quick
and then
the rooster stops pursuing him and i'm
like okay i'll come out and play
so i go into his backyard right and then
that [ __ ] comes up to me
and i just start kicking the air oh and
that food dodges my kick
and pecks my other foot and i'm like oh
[ __ ]
and i started running right and they're
like no don't run
and when you start running they chase
you dude yeah and they don't stop
and they [ __ ] peck you with the back
of your ankles and [ __ ] dude that
rooster just me
made you a baby that was a [ __ ] dude
and i was crying
my friend and his big brother were
cracking the [ __ ] up and his mom was
like what's happening and she started
laughing at me
and i'm just running around the backyard
for my life while this [ __ ] rooster
keeps pecking at my
[ __ ] eyes and i'm like i try
i just like that your friend kicks them
and the guy's like you are a kicking
master and then you kick and then like
hello there he's like you [ __ ]
well i think we're gonna have a fun time
[Laughter]
wow i know i still have like i still
have a grudge against that bully
i do have dreams till this day of me
kicking that [ __ ] like a soccer ball
dude
and landing a good one right in its
chest so he flies
that would sit with me too i never got
to kick it i love
i love animals but like um
well i had to i want to kick a [ __ ]
rooster now i love that
let's go rooster kicking now what if you
meet when he goes
oh yeah he gets a [ __ ] blade and
starts [ __ ] tyler
i might i'm out
i need it to be an unfair advantage true
i mean you would think we do have the
unfair advantage though no don't oh yeah
clearly not yeah [ __ ] police chief no
it's not unfair
this one's been studying the human
anatomy the last three years
i know exactly where to stand
yeah i don't know i don't know what
happened to the chickens though i think
though for all we know it became chicken
adobo
seven chickens and there's only six
people so you can technically still
social distance properly yeah there's a
lot of space
i hope you died holding the money i
saved ten dollars
[ __ ] sucks that sucks man what a
story dude
rest in peace
[Music]
bye
[Music]